so i was really excited when i heard
about mine hunter new netflix original
series
because david fincher my favorite
director one of my favorite actresses
charlize theron were behind it and it
sounded like a refreshing take on a very
crowded true
crime drama theme instead of focusing on
the crimes totally at hand
and showing a lot of gore in action it
was more at the angle of interviewing
serial killers
it takes place in the late 70s based off
the book
mind hunter written by a former fbi
agent it was really cool that i was
using actual
serial killers in the past some were
fake but most were actual real ones
and i found it super effective the
strongest thing about this show
was the characters and it had three
central characters holden ford
played amazing by jonathan groff bill
tench and wendy carr
probably knows her from show fringe if
you watch that
that's anna torv what was so great about
these three central characters so
they're all very different in ways
similar in others but they each filled a
certain role and a
certain viewpoint that was a little
different from each other they blended
really well and conflicted against each
other a lot so you always were
questioning what side you were on in
each scene
who you were agreeing with and to me it
felt made me feel like i was in the show
and made me more into it even though it
is a very slow burn especially in the
beginning that always kept me hooked
that always kept my mind stimulated so
that never feels slow to me though
there's
between slow burn and boring slow burn
this was just a slow burn meaning
it's a lot of dialogue sure there's a
lot of waiting for like an
action to happen but the dialogue's so
good and the conflict of choices they
make
that it keeps you invested because if
you're really interested in this stuff
this is like cocaine watching this for
me anything that stimulates my mind i
love
anything david fincher-esque i love and
this has all that right here and has
great acting
and really good characters so breaking
down the three characters that you see
in this
holden was special in the sense that he
related to the serial killers the most
but that was also his crutch in a way
because he kind of become unprofessional
at times and he was also more prone to
taking on some of the
dark stuff that comes with talking to
serial killers and you can see how much
you started messing him up in the head
more and more
whereas his partner bill was more the
old school style plays by the rules and
if you're looking at a good cop bad cop
in his angle
in interviews he was always like the bad
cop he was harder on the guy yelling at
the serial killer or holden would be
more
empathetic towards a serial killer and
he's more of a man's man
bill he's the character your dad
watching show is gonna love and if you
watch football he looks exactly like the
coach or x ryan of the buffalo bills i
couldn't get that out of my head
watching and what makes him very
relatable people see a lot of family
issues they show especially with his son
his wife and they delve into that really
well building his character up
so he's very likable maybe the most
likable on the show now wendy
very intellectual she has a systematic
approach to everything it's always by
the books and she's all about
making this a program and an education
angle and she's orderly and they have to
reveal that we find out she is a lesbian
and in the late 70s it was more frowned
upon
so she's not telling anyone at work
she's keeping it hush-hush and she's
also a loner in a way
especially when she leaves her lover and
she's living alone and she's feeding
this cat and she's like consumed by her
work
as well just like all three of them but
she has no one she's really taken care
of so these three characters
super strong you see how different they
are and really hold this show down now
the opening scene of the show literally
episode one where the guy blows his head
off
was spectacular start it looked great it
was so cool
how sometimes finisher shoots from
really far away certain angles and it
really worked there when holden was
interviewing the guy holding the girl
hostage because you felt like you were
in his shoes because that's the
distance he's seeing it from so really
good stuff there a couple early episodes
that threw me off was the sound mixing
honestly
fincher clearly made the decision that
certain scenes like in the club the
sound would be louder in the background
like if you were actually in a club and
the dialogue which i get it's giving the
realistic feeling again like you're
there
but it actually was getting annoying and
sometimes you have to accept it still is
a show
and i want to hear what they're saying
and like i like literally to stand up
some scenes to hear
exactly what certain characters are
saying i noticed this more in the early
episodes it kind of tone that down
towards the middle but not even in club
scenes but in certain scenes the
background
sounds were really loud and powering
over the main character's dialogue which
got frustrating fast
so i get it as an artistic choice but i
don't know if it necessarily
is worth that sacrifice of also making
us
work hard to hear things and missing
important lines now the sidekick bill i
wasn't crazy about his acting at first i
wasn't sure if i liked it
some of the scenes the way they were
directed seemed like it was all right
you could tell where they're like all
right cut walk out
have the girl in your face and it felt
kind of like a cbs detective show of
points i feel like it got away from that
and i
got sold on his acting and i thought he
was great but it did seem like it took
him a little bit to get comfortable and
warm up into the character
but what really sold me on this show was
halfway through when you realize
it's not all about the action really
cuts that to the back burner here and
all about getting in the minds of these
serial killers and building
solid main characters now unanimously if
you read on reddit or reviews of this
show
and i'm going to agree with the public
here that the best parts are when
they're interviewing the serial killers
especially ed kemper
the actor of ed kemper camron britain
kills it as him and i loved how ed
kemper kind of loved holden and it was
most connected to holding out of anybody
they had a great theme going on about
mommy issues which they've hinted at
with holden as well so there was that
connection the two of them had and you
could tell holden was taking a liking to
him
not just for interview purposes but for
other reasons
delving into his kind of psychotic side
of him and clearly from ed kemper you
can tell the different
angles bill and holden had handling
serial killers and bill always knew
where okay stop or crossing line or
holding wants to always push the line
and for me
i always agree with holden i relay to
holden the most i think there could have
shown you he's the reason
all these things changed in the fbi and
that we got all this great research and
saved more lives and understand serial
killers better
literally coming up with the name serial
in this show which was cool he's
challenging the status quo holding all
the time and he's pushing what needs to
be done
to get the results you really want and
he knows that you have to
understand them to get anything out of
them and play their game for a bit the
serial killers so
i really related with holden here and
agree with him a lot please comment
below who you
side with the most wendy bill or holden
i'm really curious to that because i
wonder because i feel like a lot of
people are disagree with that
for sure which is good that's i think
the whole point of this show is to get
you thinking on many different
sides and angles now jerry brutos guy
was hysterical
in love with the high heels and i love
how they related these cases to holden's
life
and that when he's having sex with his
girlfriend he sees her in the heels and
he's freaked out by it now
i was talking to someone i work with and
they were saying no he was just looking
at the heels
freaked out because he just worked on a
case with a serial killer with the heels
and they looked just like the ones he
used
but i took it as it was partly that but
it was also him kind of being attracted
to the heels a little more now and he
was taking that on
and developing that from being around
that thinking that's how i looked at it
so
that was really well done and
interesting because remember too
there is a scene where he rubs his
girlfriend's feet and she's like oh are
you getting the feet nap too
big hint there so that was also showing
you how he's picking up some tendencies
from these serial killers by opening
himself up so much to them and then when
they talk to richard speck the serial
killer that was a different level of
nutty
really good scene and holden really
pushes the limits there
and shows what needs to be done to get
stuff
out of these serial killers and he gets
a lot out of him but then almost pushes
him too far that he throws the bird in
the fan which was awesome really cool
and so well shot that whole scene and
that was a david fincher
directed episode towards the end because
he did the last two and the way this
show
ended with holden's story i really
thought it did a really
good job at showing how lonely he got at
the end and alone
losing his girlfriend losing the fbi's
trust losing his partner's trust
kind of distancing himself from
everybody and getting closer and closer
to his subjects the serial killers and
it really showed that feeling everyone
looking down on you especially when he's
in the office certain ways he shot
scenes from his angle i've felt that
feeling before and i could really relate
to that
and that he just felt like no one agrees
with me am i crazy
am i wrong here but this man changed the
game so i was constantly rooting for him
and it shows how much people who
are trend setters and think differently
have to push through so many people
so many layers keep trying new things
and keep going which i love about this
story and that's why it shows how holden
was resilient
now wendy wendy got very unlikable
towards the end to me she really pissed
me off when she played the tape for the
boss
i thought that she was a little more
rogue because when we first met her
she was also all about changing the game
of the fbi and giving it more
updated material and she's very
intellectual person but she became a
little more like
to the system of the fbi towards the end
which i thought was a little offer
character
but there's obviously a reason they're
doing that but i started liking her less
and less each episode i hope she becomes
a little more likable because she's part
of the three
team duo here that we're rooting for but
her character came a little bit of a
disappointment but her acting was still
on par and she did a great job at making
you kind of
not knowing how to feel about her and
again can we trust her now bill really
grew on me i love that he couldn't
really handle the dark stuff like holden
could and have you always mentioned how
holden how is this guy
basically immune to this and how does he
just handle this so easy phil is clearly
the most human here
and feeling of emotions and bill really
here for us in the audience he's the
normal one he's the one
normal people can relate to the most
he's sensible he's realistic he's
rational
he's protective of the one he loves
where holden is more like a lone ranger
and the mystery to hold him is
fascinating because we don't know
anything about his past
which is going to give this show many
seasons to come i think and i love about
this season was they left so much open
and built so many seeds to great
storylines to come
they didn't blow their load let's say
this whole seasons they just focused on
building
strong characters and a good story now
some people complained about the school
episode with a guy tickling the feet the
principal
but i really enjoyed it i thought it was
necessary to show more of how holden's
thinking is
that it really is for the good but it
also showed a really good debate that
can kind of relate to current times now
with all the harassment scandals in
hollywood of like
when is it okay this person's definitely
the wrong or when is it too
preventing and that maybe this guy
didn't mean bad he just saw it the wrong
way the principal and wasn't getting
that he was coming off creepy but then
you see the
wife come up the elevator saying he lost
his job it was his life and then you
kind of feel like maybe holden was wrong
there and he's feeling that himself that
was a really good thing that got you
thinking about as well my one of my
biggest gripes in this show this season
was
i liked the girlfriend people complained
about her acting i thought she did a
good job though she was more
of not your typical girlfriend she was
independent she was like
very hippie which makes sense at the
time and mysterious so i don't think she
was
acting bad or boring i think that she
just knew how to play that character
that they wanted she served her purpose
well
what threw me off was the man patrick
she was going to school with that holden
was getting suspicious about
he goes to her exhibit at school it's in
that dark room and sees her cozying up
with patrick and then
she sees him see her and he runs away
and she runs after him
but they never touch on that again it
feels like the next episode they just
forgot about it they didn't even
address it so that was annoying to me
and kind of frustrated me with the rest
of holden's story with this girl from
the end when they broke up because he
didn't even bring it up
when she was dumping him which i thought
he would so that kind of just slipped by
because they ended an episode on that so
that was weird to me i also love in the
show how they're opening each episode
with something that will lead to other
seasons showing pieces of the btk
killer who's another real serial killer
and he's had stuff happen as recent of
2005
so this is probably gonna be a story
that's always little pieces for a couple
seasons and then we get it
towards the end which is really cool and
well thought out because he started
doing stuff in the 70s and it kept going
for a long time he's a serious
serial killer and they're thinking the
show out it shows me which is great it
was so great about holden's character
was like this fanboy thing he had about
serial killers that freaked phil out
like he hung up the kemper cards that
were sent to him
in the office and then when he's
mentioning about serial killers he might
meet the bill
bill's like what do you want an
autograph from them and it's true there
is that part of him that just admires it
which can be looked at many ways but
clearly the best scene this whole season
was when kemper got up in the hospital
and hugged holden at that moment holden
knows camper could have easily just
snapped his neck
and he would have been dead so he has
like serious breakdown
and runs out into the hallway and ends
on such a crazy note with him like
really losing himself really making
interesting for where it's going to go
next season and it really was great too
how they ended
with everyone getting caught by the fbi
as well for covering something up so
that's another great storyline they lead
into they have so much conflict they
build up at the end that they left
us hanging on which is great it makes
you want to watch more and
it's already promising good stories
honestly for next season for sure so
david fincher
kills it again i'm trying not to be
biased i love david fincher but i'm
judging him like any other show
and he still to me did great i love this
show it made me think the whole time
it's right up my alley
people who love psychological type
thriller
a lot of thinking and a very smart show
this is it
there's no way you can play with the
characters here the acting across the
board was great the writing was solid
and i i cannot wait
for more i usually don't binge shows
this one i binged
that's how much i loved it i'm gonna
give this season a nine
super great for an opening season and it
seems like a show if you're putting
stock in it's just gonna get better and
better and i feel like second season
people are kind of in the middle about
season one which i've seen a lot i feel
like the second season is just gonna be
different level so i cannot wait again
please comment below what you thought of
the season
as a whole did you like it what would
you give it as a rating one to ten
and who would you relate to the most of
these characters i really want to know
let me know down below who you agreed
with whose side you're on
i can't wait to hear your thoughts i
respond to everyone please subscribe i
do
tons of tv shows movie reviews celebrity
interviews
you name it and please follow me at
stevevarley1 on twitter and instagram
and keep coming back